[Music]
and professor woods can i start
with you tell us a little bit about how
you have reconstructed
the story of our recent covid past and
what you found when you did so
okay so so what i did was to
look at the data on the number of deaths
daily
from covid and then simply tried to back
calculate to
when those people must have been
infected on the basis of the published
information
on the the distribution of time
from infection to death so how variable
that is
and there are there are several
reasonable papers on that and and i try
to take into account the uncertainty
associated with it so you can do that
kind of
back casting if you like and work out
when when people
were infected who then sadly later died
and if you did that uh in the first wave
or or
at the second or third lockdown what you
tend to see is that it appears
that the cases were coming down somewhat
before the full lockdown was
called um and indeed if you then try and
compute the
the r number um associated uh with that
incidence rate
that also appears to be below one before
lockdown
and the reason for looking at deaths um
is is because deaths really are
you know what they say they are that you
don't have this problem of
somehow working from an unrepresentative
sample
the deaths are pretty much a census of
what happened and
also with that duration information that
there's reasonably good information
available
and so those do seem to be two
reasonably good sources of information
with which to try and infer what was
going on right um tim spector your zoe
app has been collecting
m covid infections data in real time
does that sound right to you what
professor wood has just outlined
well we started collecting data on about
the 24th
of march last year and so we weren't
really a position to mark the
exact timing of the first wave but on
the second wave you had quite a lot of
data by then the second wave we did
and there's no doubt that according to
our data
the uh it had already started we'd pass
the peak before
um lockdown so it was already going down
when the official lockdown came into
play
and on the the third lockdown
uh it it really coincided
depending on exactly where you you put
it but i think you
most of us looking at it thought the
peak had already passed by the time of
the
third lockdown so i think it would
support
um simon's view that based on the death
rates
you know looking at the the incidence
rates the new cases
uh the numbers uh were already past
their peak when when the official
lockdown came in
although of course people might have
reacted differently
uh on the build-up to those things so
the exact timing
isn't clear but certainly it does uh
raise a big question mark over this all
right now professor woods
and let's look at the second lockdown
that's the one at the focus of the
political
discussion right now um if your studies
show
that cases were not rising when the
second lockdown was introduced as
the politicians had thought at the time
that doesn't seem to make a lot of sense
what would have forced infections down
if not if not locked down
well i think there's there were a lot of
other things going on that
you know we had this tier system uh in
place
that's one thing so there was active
management it's not as if it's
all you know complete lockdown or
nothing at all there was a lot in place
but of course
it's it's a slow process this it takes a
long time to turn the the epidemic
around
um and you kind of have to wait for your
measures to be effective i think that's
one aspect
i think the other aspect of course is
that people really do react to rising
deaths
um that you know you see the deaths
rising and suddenly you start thinking
again oh this is a serious a serious
business and i think people's behavior
is it probably changes in relation to
that
but of course i can't prove that that's
what's happened right you know there's a
lot going on in addition to the absolute
full lockdown i think
and that's that's the the key thing
right and tim spector this is a
a hugely important issue of course it
relates to our understanding of
of the so-called non-pharmaceutical
interventions the npis
and what basically what drives down
covet whether it is
government policy or whether it's
people's
behavior i guess professor wood is
saying that when people read about
things getting worse in the news perhaps
they will then change their behavior
organically i don't know if you've got
you've got so many data points here
have you noticed any correlation between
m coveted levels going up and down or
anything else happening
if it's not locked down what else could
it be
well i think what we need to move away
from is that any sort of
black or white view of this that this is
either due to lockdown
due to vaccines uh due to
um you know people's fears
i i think it is many factors influencing
this and this is why
all uh epidemic
epidemiologists really have struggled to
model most other flu epidemics etc that
they do come and go and they do
in some extent have a life of their own
and i think that's the other factor here
that
you know it's you know there's the
seasons there's the
the cold spells but there's also some
underlying wave
of the virus just coming and going in a
particular time when it
it reaches susceptible people so there
are many many factors here and i think
what we're fair with really doing wrong
in this country is
is to think it's an all or nothing thing
about lockdowns
and absolutely right the reason that the
r value
uh never keeps going down at the same
rate as people relax
because they don't see their neighbors
being driven to hospital
and the opposite occurs that when police
sirens are around
and you know their friends are dropping
down those people are going to stay
indoors and that's just normal you know
and
that's been going on for hundreds of
years that idea that when you're
surrounded by
danger so i think you know and
now at the moment of course we've got
vaccines uh coming into play
which half the population are under so
the idea that you can say it's all due
to this or due to that
is really uh crazy and i think this is
we've over emphasized
definitely the the effects of government
uh prescribed lockdowns uh
and ignored all these other factors that
definitely as equally important as we've
seen from these you know at least two
out of the three lockdowns
it you know it was already on the way
down before
official rules came into play and i
think you know we can argue about
what proportion of it but clearly it
can't have been due
just to the lockdown uh other factors
were already in play um
simon wood in your research you also
look
at cov in sweden which of course
famously
never locked down in any of the of the
coveted waves why do you think
sweden is is relevant to
understanding the british situation
given how vastly different these two
countries are
well i think there's a couple of things
to say there i mean one is sweden
tends to get discarded as some sort of
outlier but really
it's the only place that did the
experiment and did something really
really different as a western european
country
now of course it is different in many
ways to the uk but on the other hand
it's also similar in some ways that the
densities in swedish cities are not that
different to the densities in uk cities
they do have large immigrant populations
um and and so on so i think
i think the thing about sweden is simply
that you know there are things there
that are very very puzzling
um if what you require is complete
prescriptive lockdown in order to bring
the epidemic under control it's it's
puzzling
that the catastrophe widely predicted in
sweden simply never happened
that if you take the same models that
predicted you know really bad outcomes
in the uk
they predicted also extremely bad
outcomes for sweden and those things
didn't materialize
under the swedish policy so i think
there are some questions to answer there
now you can't simply say
you know what they did in sweden can
translate easily to the uk there are big
differences and and
they will be part of the difference but
i think you also can't ignore what
happened in sweden
um tim spector what do you think about
the swedish example i mean
obviously it's strange to compare any
two countries in this epidemic
right now but if it were going back to
your point
about how the potency of fem of
government lockdown measures or
non-first npis non-pharmaceutical
interventions
if they're overstated then does for
example sweden tell us that the power
of people's changing behavior um is
the deciding factor it might have been
over there
absolutely and i've got swedish
colleagues you know telling me what was
happening on the ground and
we do have about 80 000 people from
sweden logging
also telling us what's going on on the
on the zoe app
so what we were seeing there is really
similar patterns of behavior
but not restricted by rules or
regulations
people would just react normally
to when they're you know they were told
the infection levels are high or low and
they would
act appropriately and that's probably
why
we saw no great difference
to to what was happening here or
actually is slightly less
uh but it is a less slightly less dense
country so i think there's more rural
elements to it but even in place like
stockholm
i think it was the natural reactions of
individuals to space themselves out
and not have meetings you know given
warnings without
necessarily backed up by legal force and
fines etc
so people were just being sensible i i
think in a way that
hasn't really been talked about in this
country right so does that
make you think that the same system
might have worked here that people might
have used
common sense or folks vit as they call
it
in sweden that the common sense and
people's behavior
might have had the same success in
driving the pandemic down
it as in sweden because as you say in
sweden the first wave and the second
wave
seemed to almost mirror the experience
of britain despite very very different
and policy responses i think that's true
in general i mean i think they're going
to be exceptions in some areas you know
we do have some
perhaps denser more deprived areas of
this country compared to sweden
where it might have been difficult to
control things
but i think it's all about giving people
the information
locally and making them feel they had a
they were in control of it and i don't
think that really happened in this
country
i don't think the dissemination of what
the real risks were to people
at different times was there it was a
general you know
constant um fear that didn't really
allow flexibility in that system and i
think perhaps the swedes were more in
touch
uh with their health authorities uh in
terms
in terms of getting that information out
to people um
plus you know that there's some evidence
that you know they
they have a higher level of higher
education as well so also might have
been able to
more easily understand that information
all right now professor woods you
referred earlier to models that showed
that sweden would face
a catastrophe that didn't lock down
disproven models that i don't know if
you're referring to the imperial college
modeling but certainly
there was a paper from imperial that
came out in december that made a very
striking claim
that britain as we all know was about a
week 10 days later
when the rest of europe to lock down the
first time around
now imperial college's studies suggest
that that delay
led to extra 20 000 deaths avoidable
covert deaths in britain
because under its modelling the number
of infections rose
exponentially right up to lockdown on
23rd of march
and then it collapsed instantly that was
the model given lots of publicity
um now you've looked at that model and
you i mean
tell me what you make of it well so
there's a couple of things to say there
actually perhaps before mentioning the
model i should say that there's also the
really interesting
results that come out from the react 2
study on what happened around the first
lockdown
and react 2 is a it's a really proper
uh statistical sample where you take a
representative sample of people
and and you're testing them for
antibodies uh to covet
and then with the people who tested
positive they then asked them about when
their symptoms had started and from that
you can also do a reconstruction of what
was happening
including at the first lockdown which of
course you can't do with the ons service
of a reaction
is a is an attempt to do what you did to
reconstruct what happened just before
lockdown one log down too
and what does the react 2 study show us
well so they've uh they've
uh reconstructed when the uh when people
were becoming infected
so the first day of infection over over
the course of
well basically up until now from from
right at the beginning on this basis and
that that study shows a very similar
pattern to what i got from the from the
death data
that once you allow for the time from
infection to first onset of symptoms
then what appears to be happening is
again that infections are dropping
before
lockdown now that of course is that that
contradicts what the imperial
the imperial study says right and so
tim specter then finally and we've got
the react to
study the ons data we've got the zoe
study from your app
all of these is it the case that all of
these suggest
that covered infections were falling
before lockdown
and if so does that mean that the whole
premise of the political conversation
that every day until lockdown was a day
of surging infections
might be based on a false premise
i think so when put in those black and
white terms yes i mean i i think
it's all a question of whether you think
the only message is the lock down
yes or no rather than giving people
you know the individual warnings
and risks to behave appropriately
and i think that's what's been
underestimated and that's also you know
why the imperial
modeling got it got it so wrong is they
just totally didn't
factor in individual change as
bodies were appearing and ambulances all
over the place which is natural human
behavior they just assumed it was you
know
no change at all until that person died
or got covered and that's completely
ridiculous so
i think i think yes looking
retrospectively you know my view is that
the lockdown was not not the key event
but it doesn't not to say that lockdowns
didn't
help somewhat in reducing the
uh the in a way that
the peak of the scale or the problem or
it continuing longer but
definitely all the analyses point that
you know would pass that point
when when they were initiated right so
as we've seen you know lots of data
now are you aware of any data tim
specter but suggests the cases were
rising at the point of lockdown
um no good data that i'm aware of no
tim spector and simon wood thanks very
much for joining me on spectator tv
[Music]
you